cette polémique machine tiens on va
évidemment parler un rapport sénatorial
porté par eliane assassi qui est la
présidente du groupe communiste y cieux
sénat a pointé le recours excessif à ces
cabinets de conseil privé notamment
durant la dernière année de ce
quinquennat près d'un milliard de
dépenses l'année dernière le
gouvernement a fait une conférence de
presse hier pour s'expliquer pour se
justifier il dit qu'il n'a rien à cacher
il a fait toute la transparence ils vous
ont convaincu les ministres n'ont
d'abord je voudrais commencer par dire
un grand merci à eliane assassi et lui
tirer un coup de chapeau ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui se met beaucoup en avant
c'est souvent comme ça avec les
communistes mais c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille beaucoup et si elle n'avait
pas été là si elle n'avait pas fait avec
évidemment l'ensemble de ses collègues
ce travail d' enquête eliane assassi
présidente du groupe communiste au sénat
personne n'aura entendu parler de ces
cabinets de conseils parce qu'évidemment
le gouvernement ne se vantait pas
d'avoir recours à ces cabinets de
conseil comme d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de gouvernements précédents et
donc ce travail de transparence qui a
été effectuée par le sénat ce qui montre
d'ailleurs que le sénat a un rôle
extrêmement utile dans notre démocratie
ce travail là il a été fait et c'est
grâce à eliane assassi et ses collègues
que ces réalités ont pu être ont pu être
pardon mise à jour cette affaire elle
est scandaleuse plus d'un milliard
d'euros qui ont été investis dans ces
cabinets de conseils pour faire le
travail que l'administration aurait dû
faire moi je suis attaché un principe
simple c'est à l'administration de faire
le travail de l'administration et il y
as derrière tout ça une forme de
délitement de démantèlement de l'état de
démantèlement de la république qui moi
me révulse avec fabien roussel nous
avons profondément confiance dans
l'administration dans la capacité de
l'administration à faire face aux
problèmes plus aucun conseiller privé
terminé c'est écrit dans notre programme
et ça fera d'ailleurs des économies
parfois on nous demande comment on
finance notre programme le meilleur
moyen pour financer notre programme
c'est d'arrêter la gabegie et notamment
d'arrêter le recours au cabinet de
conseil c'est à l'état de faire le
travail de l'état c'est à
l'administration de faire le travail de
l'administration et tout ça s'inscrit
dans une logique globale chez makro qui
est une logique de méfiance de défiance
vis-à-vis des services de l'état il faut
faire l' inverse il faut revaloriser
l'état dans une république forte on a
besoin d'un état fort et on a besoin
d'avoir confiance dans l'administration
et il ya un deuxième sujet qui est
fondamental qu'est la question de
l'optimisation fiscale on peut pas
continuer l'état ne peut pas continuer
de signer des contrats avec des boîtes
qui se paie le luxe de ne pas payer
d'impôts en france et
ils étaient dans le deleware enfin c'est
quand même invraisemblable et fabien
roussel est le seul candidat à avoir
posé cette question de l'évasion et de
l'optimisation fiscale dans cette
campagne c'est 80 milliards d'euros au
moins qui partent en fumée chaque année
vous voulez mettre fin au recours à des
cabinets privés par par par l'état et
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose une pratique existe depuis
très longtemps qui peut être aussi utile
dans certains cas est ce qu'on n'a pas
intérêt à revenir à une plus juste
mesure c'est à dire encadrer les choses
là ce que le point que le rapport
sénatorial c'est une dérive c'est les
montants qui sont très importants mais
cette pratique là elle n'est pas en soi
scandale aussi qu'on me fasse à ce
moment là la démonstration que les
cabinets de conseils ça faire des choses
que l'état ne sait plus faire et si
c'était le cas et si c'était le cas ça
prouverait qu'on a trop dépensé l'état
et qu'on a au contraire besoin de
renforcer la fonction publique de
renforcer notre administration mais à
force de démanteler l'ena à force de
taper sur la fonction publique on en
arrive à une perte de compétences du
service public et c'est un problème qui
est réel et auquel il faut
impérativement remédier j'ajoute un
élément quand vous voyez que des gens
qui ont fait de grandes écoles des
polytechniciens
travail pour ces cabinets de conseil ont
leur à payer leurs études non seulement
on leur à payer leurs études mais en
plus de ça ils ont été payés pour faire
leurs études et derrière ils vont
travailler dans des cabinets de conseil
qui ne payent pas d'impôts en france
enfin vous imaginez où on en est à quel
niveau de gabegie on en est arrivé ces
gens arnaque l'état j'entendais l'autre
jour comment vous faites c'est à dire gg
des études dans des hautes écoles
publiques vous ne pouvez pas traîner
pris d'abord vous devez 10 ans à l'état
c'est le signe avec vous c'est le
contrat que vous signez et dans sa liste
toujours au lycée ledoux il devait
rembourser il faut veiller effectivement
à ce que ceux qui n'ont pas rempli leur
engagement décennal rembourse parce
qu'ils n'ont pas réalisé leur société le
cas aujourd'hui c'est toujours le cas il
faut vérifier que ce soit toujours bien
le cas mais surtout de nom mais dont on
n'a pas - je lui dis quand on a fait
polytechnique derrière on ne travaille
pas pour des cabinets de conseil qui
arnaquent l'état tout ça donne quand
même un sentiment de 2,2 de révolte
profond vis-à-vis de ce qui est en train
de se passer j'entendais l'autre jour le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent qui disait il faut avoir recours
au cabinet de conseil avec parcimonie
mais enfin qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'il faut arnaquer l'état
avec parcimonie enfin où on en arrive je
pense que nous avons besoin de
responsables politiques d'un président
de la république qui retrouve le sens de
l'état du respect de l'état du respect
aujourd'hui que le président de la
république a perdu le sens de l'état
quand on a recours à des cabinets de
conseil qui arnaquent l'état en faisant
de l'optimisation fiscale en faisant un
travail que l'administration est capable
de faire on perd le sens de l'état a
besoin de retrouver ce sens de l'état et
ce sens de l'intérêt chez hk par les
scandales d'état comme le font certains
bruits jc oui c'est un scandale d'état
moi je suis pas dans une logique
complotisme je ne dis pas qu'il y a une
espèce de complot qui s'est tramé jeudi
qu'il y a des gens qui ont théorisé le
fait que l'état était un poison il
fallait se débarrasser et qui pensent
que le privé est systématiquement mieux
que le service public on a la preuve du
contraire quand vous voyez que pour
faire la réforme des apl qui qui qui
quand même coûte très cher pour beaucoup
de ménages modestes on a eu recours à
mckinsey franchement
[Musique]